we're down here at cherrybrook
technology high school with australia's
favorite math teacher eddie wu
in the current coronavirus crisis
teachers across the country
have been looking towards online
learning which is something that eddie
has been excelling at for years
[Music]
[Music]
i'm proud to declare i love mathematics
[Music]
[Applause]
i used to believe that maths was about
root learning inscrutable formulas
to solve abstract problems that didn't
mean anything to me
there's a mathematical reality woven
into the fabric of the universe
just because mathematics doesn't come
naturally that doesn't mean you can't
work with it and uh come to an
understanding of it
[Music]
eddie welcome to oneplus one curt thanks
for having me
why should i fall in love with math
mathematics is
one of the most incredibly creative
things that humanity has ever come up
with it didn't start that way
it started with people making sure they
had settled accounts properly that they
were
selling the right number of cows for
horses but from very practical
beginnings
it really is truly a creative pursuit
that number one
allows us to understand the world around
us and i think that's something we all
want
people want to be you know able to look
at these perplexing things around us
like why snowflakes if you've ever seen
a picture of one under a microscope have
this beautiful
symmetry and geometry to them despite
the fact that they kind of just
randomly form in the air when it's cold
and wet what's going on there
what's the what's the bottom of that
mystery and the answer is mathematics
answers that not only does it help us
understand the world though
it lets us achieve great things it lets
us you know
manipulate the world around us it sends
human beings
to the moon and beyond that's the power
that mathematics has
so i feel it's worthy of your love kurt
i i feel like when i went through school
i remember doing maths and then
uh my teacher telling me you need to
know this because you're not going to be
carrying around a calculator
24 7. it is fast forward 20 years
every student is literally carrying
around a calculator and more in their
pocket
in like a mobile device why
is math still important why do we still
need to teach that to our kids
there's a few different ways to answer
that question it is quite funny that
truly we have access to more calculating
power
than we ever could and that might make
people think well therefore
i don't really need to know how to add
subtract division
trigonometry calculus don't i need to i
can just let technology take care of
that
and i would argue a big reason why
no in fact that technology is more of a
reason
to understand what mathematics is i'll
give you an example that piece of
technology
inside our pockets it lets us access a
big wide world
out there you know people probably never
really understood
how much of a difference the internet
would make on society
but the internet is something that is
run by algorithms it's run by
mathematics when we jump on to say
social media
which is not just for entertainment
that's something which changes
politics and elections and all kinds of
really fundamental things about our
world
what we see and what we don't see is
governed by
formulas hidden from view and so in many
ways
there's even more reason now that that
technology is around to say
hold on a second there's mathematics
underneath here that i think i need to
make sure i
understand and i could go on for more
reasons you know when i'm at the shops
sure i have that technology there but
that's for doing a simple calculation
what about when i'm listening to a news
report and someone throws up a statistic
or a chart we've seen a lot of those in
recent times they
inform our decision-making should we
come out of um you know
lock down now or later are we are we
doing well
battling this virus or are we actually
struggling
mathematics is what answers all those
questions
you mentioned how uh technology and the
internet has changed the way we live
it's also played such a big role in your
career
can you tell me can you tell me a little
bit about youtube
wishtube is what happens when someone
appreciates dad jokes name's a youtube
channel
i uh i started taking classroom
videos of what i'd filmed a normal
lesson that i would deliver in the
classroom
i started taking them and putting them
online about seven years ago now
and it was really not with a kind of
global stage
in view it was just one student of mine
who was very ill and
and couldn't make it to school and i
wanted to provide him
part of the experience these peers were
having i remember when i was at school
not because i was sick but because my
mother was very sick
that there were times when i had to miss
a fair bit of school
and particularly in a subject like
mathematics and okay i don't know if you
can relate to this experience
you might miss a day or a single lesson
or even 10 minutes of a lesson and then
you look back up at the whiteboard
and you just think what does any of this
mean i feel like i'm missing some
crucial pieces here
and i'm just completely out to see and
in mathematics because
so many of the pieces of knowledge and
skill fit together
i knew that this boy who was going to
miss more than just a few pieces of
knowledge
um he was going to miss weeks of school
at a time
would not be able to recover from that
so i took my
recordings of class put them online so
that he could access them and
it was quite a surprise to me that so
many other people would find that
valuable and here we are almost a
million subscribers later it's just kind
of mind boggling
so what's the height of my square
there's an a here
and it's me so you just add them
together what are some other responses
yeah i'm sure that there are your
audiences worldwide
there are mathematicians out there that
are tuning in
what are some of the responses that
you're getting uh you absolutely get the
whole range of different responses and
uh to start with you know i'm a high
school teacher so i think about
children who aged 12 roughly to 18 and
that's kind of my
target audience that's who's in the
classroom with me but it's quite
surprising to me that actually
they only make up a small slice of who's
watching there's people
younger who are looking for further
learning they're just curious and they
kind of think
calculus no one's told me that i'm not
allowed to learn that yet so i'm just
going to go look it up
and there's people beyond that who've
left school and i think many people
share this experience of going through
mathematics in
their formal education never really
clicking with it
but still being curious and wanted to
know what was that all about
what did all those x's and y's mean so
quite frequently in fact one of the most
common
comments that i get on videos was ha
this finally makes sense of
pythagoras theorem or this other formula
that i learned which to me is delightful
that it's something which
can make sense of something which is in
their brain but they're never quite
comprehended
there's a lot of maths uh out there
online youtube there's plenty of videos
why are there 63 million views
on youtube you know what kurt
in all honesty i wish i knew the full
answer to that question because
i think to myself as you said there's
not just lots of maths videos
there's lots of all kinds of things on a
platform like youtube
immensely entertaining things things
which are crafted and designed to grab
your attention
and hold it and i'm honestly um quite
perplexed
why would you of all the things you
could spend your time on go and watch
some math voluntarily i'm not forcing
anyone
i think probably one of the things
that's more unusual about what i do is
that
my students are there in the classroom
when i'm recording it really is just a
normal
lesson like i'm delivering every single
day and
even though i've had some teachers say
to me that sounds crazy why would you
put a camera and record your own
mistakes when you make them
and you know your students are
chattering away on the side and you have
to say hey you know
focus on this isn't that you know
something you feel vulnerable doing
but i actually think their interaction
and
and the fact that when i speak to you
for example right now
i'm speaking in a whole different way
than i would if i was speaking to a
camera lens and
no one speaks to a human being the way
they would speak to a disembodied empty
room
so i actually think it's part of that
human dynamic that
helps me to teach better and i wonder if
that's the thing that's become helpful
to people out there
i'm a i'm a pdhpe teacher i
i have to teach children hurdles
uh i don't have a lot of expertise in
hurdles but
what's more important to you expertise
or passion
wow when it comes to selecting between
expertise
and passion in some ways i feel like
that's asking which wing of the plane
would you like to keep
because they really are these these
complementary pieces that i mean when we
think of all of
the teachers who made a difference on us
i think about the the teachers i had
particularly in high school who i
remember
now and and some of whom i remember i
remember
them more than i remember any individual
lesson that they gave me and i'm sure
i'm not alone in that experience
the expertise and the passion really had
to be
married together i had several teachers
who
who knew so much but could not convey
that in a personal and relational way so
i didn't learn much
from them but at the same time just
because you can develop great rapport
with someone if you don't have anything
to help them to learn if you have no
expertise to share
then what is the value of that
relationship i think it's important to
recognize as well
expertise takes many forms um there's
expertise in a mathematics classroom but
there's also
expertise that say our student
counsellors have which
is nothing to do with academics but is
is very deep and complicated as well so
i'd really like to not have to choose
between those uh
this time we're in the middle of 2020
it's a turbulent
year for teachers students uh in
parents you're a dad of three kids i've
got two i
um i could teach 30 children
no problems you know like i'm i'm down
with that but
you get me to homeschool my six-year-old
and i'm grabbing for the bottle at two
o'clock
you're not alone cat you're not alone
how did you deal with uh
with the current situation i i'm i can't
lie
it was an immense challenge um i
relished it it was fantastic
but it did absolutely help me learn that
uh
when i think about the dynamic between a
parent and a child
i could say yeah it's harder like you
said put me in front of a classroom
suddenly i'm fine i'm like a duck to
water it's everything is very natural in
some ways
but you have a very different
relationship with your children we all
do
uh we teach them very different things
at the end of 53 minutes
at this high school the bill goes and i
can say bye and i don't have to worry
about you
making sure your meal is finished making
sure you've got all the right clothes on
and the right body parts all these kinds
of things that as a parent
are a whole different story so i feel
like i definitely
learned a lot more respect for my
children's teachers but i also recognize
every parent out there who's been
struggling through that don't be too
hard on yourself you're teaching your
children
helping them learn through every
experience you have with them not just
when you're
remote learning what advice would you
give to those parents at home who had
now taken that primary role as educator
if you're a parent who's at home
struggling with
trying to make sure yeah you're helping
me help me you can't i totally get it i
mean
i think what's important is if there's
one
lesson which i think every parent can
take on which i've really tried to
give myself my own advice is to be a
co-learner
with your child um i'm a mathematics
teacher
but actually the way that even my own
subject has been taught
even as subject as timeless as
mathematics
it's different for my kids going through
you know 20 plus years after
when i went through and so i'm actually
sitting beside them saying
okay the most valuable thing i can give
to you now is not
knowledge that i can transmit to you i'm
not their teacher the way that their
classroom teacher is but
i want to show them hey let's struggle
together let's learn something new
together let's discover something and
experience that joy through that
struggle side by side i think that's
something that
every parent can do i feel like in the
middle of the school day
while we were homeschooling that the
video from
our teacher or my boys teacher was a
lifesaver
how does it feel that teachers around
the country are now looking to youtube
but now look into eddie wu to see
how do we do this i'm equal parts
you know delighted and terrified
it's it's a real weight of
responsibility to know
that people are looking at your practice
and i've always had an open
door policy in my classroom whenever my
colleagues want to see how do you do
this
yeah absolutely come on in it's a bit of
a different premise when suddenly
it's a country or even now i've had
colleagues from
the us who are trying to work out uh
school reopenings you know
it's a different part of the school year
for them obviously and they're now
trying to work out how do we transition
to this
you've got resources that can help us
there and i'm so glad i can be helpful
to them
but i'd be lying if i didn't feel
nervous at all um it really makes sure
that i
i'm sharp and i'm giving absolutely the
best i can every time i'm in the
classroom
even more than when i'm thinking about
the kids in front of me
well how are the kids going do you think
children are adapting to our current
situation
it's such a mixed bag when i think about
how children have responded to
um this you know cataclysmic change in
the way that their their whole world
functions what's been amazing to me is
to see
how resilient some of these kids are
it's astonishing when we think about
you know the word unprecedented gets
thrown around a lot in these times
but in some senses these kids don't know
much else this is kind of all right
there was just a couple months in the
year where i just had to take charge of
my own learning
and make sure i was responsible for that
and accountable to that
but at the same time i think it
certainly has the situation has revealed
a lot of inequities across
our system i'm really fortunate to be in
a school that is incredibly well
resourced you've got kids who have no
trouble
accessing technology and internet and
devices and all the rest but it's
definitely not consistent
across new south wales or indeed the
country and i think that's really shown
a light
that we need to address that we can't
let that be something which just goes
back to normal
inequality at the moment is it seems to
be
showing up more than ever especially
when it's access to
say online equipment to be able to take
classes
into the home what do we need to do to
adjust to that
there's small changes and there's also
really big structural changes
that need to be made when we think about
small changes um some things are easy to
solve you know i know there was there
was programs for providing technology
and improving internet access
to different families and communities
and that's fantastic we absolutely need
to do that
but in fact there are some much deeper
problems that you can't solve by sending
someone a laptop
as an example in mathematics one of the
most common
problems that we face is that we do not
have enough qualified mathematics
teachers
especially in remote areas and so many
of the teachers who we are so grateful
for and they're doing their best but
they're what we call
out of field so they are qualified in a
subject other than mathematics
and we're saying to them hey look we
need someone to teach
these year sevens and eight mathematics
can you help out you know
you're going to have to be provided
support to learn that but you're going
to go in there
it's not your main expertise and you're
going to have to sort of learn as you go
now that is an enduring problem that
when we think about why that is the case
it's because
you know how do we actually make sure
that these uh communities are not just
having
a qualified teacher come in but then
just as quickly
leave that community i know i've worked
with teachers who have gone out to work
in places like
broken hill and eloquent and the first
question that they get asked when they
arrive in the school is
how long are you going to be here for
because there's this assumption from the
students they know people
they come in and then they leave and
that expertise doesn't have the
opportunity to actually grow there and
support those communities in a in a
longitudinal way
why is there a worldwide shortage of
mathematics teachers
when we think about what it takes to be
a mathematics teacher
we talked before about expertise and
passion and and the importance of
relationship with students and when you
think about the overlap of different
skills that you need to be
a great mathematics teacher i think if
you have
all of those skills there are a hundred
other professions careers almost all of
which are far more lucrative
and gain much more respect in society
and standing in society
than being a mathematics teacher in fact
i still remember
with every good intent that several of
my teachers
when they heard that i wanted to go into
education at university
they were the people who were the most
strong in saying don't do this you could
do
so many other things and i find that
heartbreaking but at the same time
they had nothing but the best of intents
for me i think they really thought
you could do something where you can
earn twice as much money
you can be much more comfortable work
not as hard
and have have you know a great a great
home to live in and especially in a
place
like sydney and so there's a lot of
change in society that needs to happen
about the way we view our educators
and the way that we we attract them what
salaries and awards look like they're
all part
of that uncomfortable but very important
conversation we have
around attracting people into this
profession are we paying teachers enough
could i always feel it's a bit
disingenuous for me to give
an honest answer to that question
because kurt if i said to you
yes we are paying them enough you'd say
really and if i if i said no
i would think people would say of course
he would say no
i have a bit of a vested interest in
saying that
but i can definitely put this to you
when i think about
my friends who would have made fantastic
mathematics educators
when i think about um the son of a taxi
driver
i met once who said to his dad
dad uh i i can't be i can't be a math
teacher i know i'd be a really good one
but i could do and he just listed off
all of the different things that
the different career paths that he could
access where he knew
he'd be great at them as well but could
just earn
double triple ten times more said dad i
can't do that
he's responding to the incentives that
society's given to him who could blame
him
for that so in lieu of saying no kurt
i simply can only say let's look at the
situation
that we've created for ourselves in
society where we do not have
enough mathematics teachers we have so
few
that by the end of year 7 to 10 by the
end of year 10
only about 13 of those students across
the country
have had a trained mathematics teacher
every single year
13 87
of all of us at least one year likely
more
we had to do our very best learning from
someone who was
also doing their very best to teach a
subject that was not their area of
expertise
what why are we surprised those students
are then struggling and are missing some
of those pieces and then say
i can't learn this the main reason why
people feel like
people say to me every time i meet them
oh you're a mathematics teacher
i could never do maths everyone can do
maths provided with the right support
and guidance but that's support and
guidance usually isn't there
this is the situation we've created for
ourselves in society
by the economic decisions we've made i
feel like that answers the question
pretty comprehensively the reason why i
would become a teacher was because they
a teacher would sit down with me and say
that the most powerful part of you is
your desire you
that will be the thing that will get you
through life that is the most important
thing more important than a
than an exam mark that is what you need
to nurture
and it was the thing that i needed to
hear at that point in time
did you have a teacher that that pointed
you in the direction that you needed to
go as a kid
hmm wow
there are so many teachers of mine who i
have this
unrepayable debt to who did exactly what
you just mentioned in terms of
uh nudging me in a direction and saying
you know what you have
you have an opportunity um you have
gifts many of
which are not because of you you were
born in this country because well for me
my parents migrated here i didn't choose
that um i was
i was raised in an area with amazing
schools that helped me to really
uh cultivate the skills that i had from
from home
and that are part of my dna so many of
those teachers
were sort of indirect in the way they
did that i think about say
my agriculture teacher in year 7 mr
brown he never had this moment where he
said to me you know
edward what you really need to do is is
x you know go in this direction
but he gave me this example of someone
who
cared for me as a human being before he
cared for me as a student
i wasn't the most successful father
there but that was never an obstacle
to mr brown always coming beside me
patiently saying okay were you trying to
learn
how to do this let me try and understand
the piece that's missing
and then get you to the point where you
understand you can answer a question or
you can
be able to make good decisions to help
your things grow and so
mr brown taught me human beings first
relationships first and that's something
which
as a teacher now every single day that
i'm in a
school that's a lesson which has carried
with me i'm so delighted that i get to
try and
teach the next generation that same
lesson i hope i can
are we talking enough about how
how we can get every teacher to buy into
that conversation to buy into the
the power of belief when you put it in a
kid
that's a really hard question to answer
because i have a lot of empathy for
every teacher out there who knows that
that is true
that the power of belief that conviction
can unlock
a child's potential which is an amazing
thing to see
but at the same time the reason why i
have empathy with those teachers out
there struggling to actually do that
is because whilst we would love to do
that every single day there's
always this increasing number of
responsibilities aside
from caring for a student and being able
to give our classes
exactly what they need which often are
distractions which
you know paperwork and processes and
administration are important they help
us do our jobs
better but when when they take us away
from
the core part of the work which is our
students and our ability to
help them grow that that's really
unfortunate and many students
don't get that experience because their
teachers are distracted by the burden of
all these other things they have to do
as educators do you think that community
are
valuing right now that that contribution
do you think that they're seeing the
role of a teacher completely different
because of the
the setting that we found ourselves i
really hope that
one of the silver linings out of this
experience is that
seeing our kids uh watching them
struggle
with learning face-to-face rather than
that being a distant and sort of
experience that you're separated from
because they do that during nine to
three and then i
i see them after it's all over i really
hope that is helping our society
appreciate that more
and i hope that that's a launch pad you
know just to say oh i get it
that's really tough is clearly not
enough we've got to make decisions we've
got to change policies and structures
to enable the work that matters in
schools to flourish
we have a lot of progress to make still
how was your experience as a
as a primary school student or in the
education system itself
i had a really mixed experience going
through school
myself i remembered being you know a
person who didn't fit in very well
at primary school in particular growing
up
as an asian face that spoke only
english uh i really felt like i didn't
belong anywhere
i didn't look like most of the people in
my classroom and those few occasions
where i got to go back
to where my family uh had its ancestry
um i could i could blend in if i didn't
open my mouth
and as soon as i said something it's
kind of like you foreigner what are you
doing here
and so there really was a sense of kind
of oh i
i was kind of never in a place where i
knew who i belonged with and you know i
think in some ways
every child goes through some version of
that um
whether it was kind of like oh i wasn't
sporty when i was growing up or i was
way taller than my friends or who
whatever experience it was and so
primary school was difficult for me um
because of that and i certainly
didn't feel like i had a way to
find my own identity in that place and
find
the people who understood that identity
that really changed i think when i went
to high school
and um for the first time really was
surrounded by people who
loved learning in the same way that i
did but also understood
what it was like to be a little out at
sea that sort of
uh second generation migrant experience
where
i i feel down in my bones i'm australian
people ask me where are you from i say i
was born in camperdown like is that the
answer you were looking for
but to be able to say yes that's part of
my identity and also
where my parents and grandparents come
from are also part of my personality and
my values
to be able to marry those together was
something which i think finally clicked
when i was in high school and and then
got to flourish as i went beyond that i
don't know a teacher that's got into the
profession
for recognition or riches
but you've received one of those moments
that
are just so unique as as local hero of
the year
how do you how do you experience that
moment being held up to the country
for for the thieves that you do look it
was absolutely
um it was it was it was an out
out-of-body experience
to be frank with you and let's just
let's just take a step back for a second
right
like the phrase australian of
the year is just such a like i've had to
i've been asked to introduce myself
sometimes
um on like at a conference or um at an
interview and it's kind of like
i'd say oh hi hi i'm my name is eddie
where i'm a high school mathematics
teacher and now
they'll sort of interrupt me and say no
no can you say that thing about
you know your industry and i say how can
anyone with a straight face say
hi i'm eddie wu i'm one of the
australians of the year just seems
bizarre
and i very much feel you know people
talk about imposter syndrome
right as if that's something we've got
to kind of get over
and sort of um you know come to the
point where you feel like no no this is
something
you deserve you're in the right spot
i've never been able to with a serious
face say
yeah sure this is a a mantle and a
title that i can say i just they deserve
i
i've never felt that way and i still
don't um i i literally meant by the way
that it was an out of body experience i
remember
when the prime minister read out my name
the the bottom half of my body
i just lost sensation i kind of thought
to myself oh no i'm gonna have to get up
and walk
how am i gonna do this i i just i
thought this this can't be real
um and i think about all of the i knew
that i was there not as an individual
but as a representative of what
education means
and what educators stand for and and
that's the sense in which i can say
all right i can i can be here i can
receive this
on behalf of uh what education means to
our society i'm here to say
all of education every educator is
valued should be valued
that's why i'm holding this as a proud
representative just like i guess a
you know a captain holds up the trophy
at the end of a game that they've been
victorious of not just to say
uh we won but to say this victory
belongs to all of us
matt i love what you do i want uh i want
i want someone like you to be in the
front of my kids class so
thanks for joining me on oneplus one
okay it's all my pleasure
[Music]
you